- GENTLEMEN, IT HAS BEEN
A PLEASURE
AND AN HONOR TO MEET YOU
AND YOUR--YOUR PEOPLE.
THE U.S. GOVERNMENT SUPPORTS YOU
IN EVERY POSSIBLE WAY.
IDEOLOGICALLY, OF COURSE.
HOWEVER, WE CANNOT OFFER
ANY MILITARY AID AT THIS TIME.
- WITH ALL DUE RESPECT,
AMBASSADOR,
WE NEED MORE THAN THAT.
- WE ARE DEALING WITH TERRORISM
ON A DAILY BASIS.
- OH, THAT'S SO UNFORTUNATE.
- WARLORDS OVERRUN VILLAGES.
- YES, THAT'S REGRETTABLE.
- RAPES, TORTURES,
ALL MANNER OF HUMAN ATROCITY.
- THAT'S REALLY SAD,
BUT THE U.S. MILITARY
IS SIMPLY SPREAD TOO THIN.
WE CAN'T AFFORD ANOTHER
INTERVENTION AT THIS TIME.
- BUT WHAT WE COULD USE
YOUR HELP WITH REALLY
IS PROTECTING
OUR VULNERABLE, PLENTIFUL,
AND NEWLY-DISCOVERED
OIL RESERVES.
- OIL?
EXCUSE ME ONE SECOND.
OPERATION GOLDEN EAGLE IS A GO.
WELCOME TO DEMOCRACY.
- UH, WE ALSO HAVE
NATURAL GASSES!
- OH, YES, A LOT.
LOTS OF IT.